hi in these videos we are going to be
talking about time complexity and Big O
notation specifically in this video
we're going to be talking about why you
should care and what it is Big O
notation and time complexity are ways of
discussing how long an algorithm is
going to take so that you can streamline
your software or your web app why do you
should care about this is pretty
straightforward do you see yourself
sitting on a web page that's loading and
loading and loading how long will you
stay there before you go to another site
some people might wait longer than
others but at the end of the day if
you're waiting on something to load or
waiting for it to do what you expect it
to do it's not going to be a good
product for the user for now let's talk
specifically about time complexity as it
relates to an algorithm you've worked
with algorithms and the bonfires an
algorithm could be one function or a set
of functions that solves a problem
instead of saying well that algorithm
will take exactly 4.5 seconds it's a
little bit more complicated than that it
kind of depends on what that algorithm
is doing and Big O notation is a way of
discussing that without going into too
much detail about what the algorithm is
specifically doing another thing you
should know about Big O notation is it's
the worst case scenario everything in
Big O notation is calculated for the
most possible data or the most possible
users so that you can kind of see ok
this might not be a problem if they have
one or two users on my site but if I
start to have thousands of users at a
time this is not going to scale well
meaning it's not gonna work well for a
larger amounts of data you might be
thinking well what about Moore's law
can't we just build a faster computer
that'll solve these algorithms faster in
a couple years and we won't really have
to worry about it short answer is no
we're talking exponentially here and no
matter how much faster the computer is
the problem is going to get a lot more
complicated faster than the computer is
going to get faster
Big O notation it comes in handy if
you're building a tool of our site and
you want it to be scalable for large
amounts of traffic Big O notation will
start to point out some places in your
code where that is going to
young users once we get more users in
the system another reason that you want
to know about big o-notation is it is a
common interview topic even if your code
runs great being able to explain why
your code runs great and why it is
efficient can be really really useful at
the end of the day what I want you to
take away from this is speed of your
algorithms matters in a way that we can
measure that is Big O notation